jackson koar
these are the numbers in his first three
big league games but hopefully he takes
them out tonight feeling
like he's got a clean slate
line driving a base hit to left field
might have been a slider or an off-speed
pitch of some sort that's his breaking
ball right there and he's
hung it up there and miles straw took
advantage there it is look at the slider
that thing backed up in him right into
home plate right into the barrel of the
bat
fastball
one away
[Applause]
oh
yeah
core
picks off miles straw logan allen's
going to be the indian starting pitcher
brought to you by your northeast ohio
ford dealers and logan coming off his
best start that we have seen all year
long against the red sox in this last
audit
and whit pulls it to third ramirez backs
up and then he kicks it into foul ground
that should be a base hit that's right
backing up on the ball how many times
have we told you when you do that as a
fielder that's a no-no really i mean
you're gonna have a hard time throwing a
speedy runner out but hey that was the
way he read the ball and he just
couldn't glove
it there's a base hit into left field
so two on and nobody out
michael a taylor he's been
the most productive royal with him
loaded five for 12.
lift it to right
that'll be deep enough to get one home
zimmer makes the play
merrifield scores lopez goes to third
center field mile straw on a dead sprint
to the warning track makes the grab to
retire the side
kansas city gets a run they lead it one
minute
and already in that first inning we saw
that fastball up to 98 miles an hour
well joel he's been ahead of all four
hitters
the change up it's a beauty and look at
how he turns it over almost like a screw
ball
there's a solid base hit into left
center field but taylor cuts it off and
zimmer came ripping around first royals
have a chance
to make a play and now a ricochet
and koar gives it to santana
and zimmer is going to be out
expanded and there's a diving play by
witt
and kowar
hey how about this one hop smash right
to wit's left that's routine he makes
those plays in his sleep adelberto
mondesi is back for the first time since
june 20th
and a base hit into center field he just
picks up where he left off answer
alberto
swings and he lines it into left center
field monday will turn and hold he'll
force a throw
and now they're running they're stopping
they are running again
and the throw ends up in left field
monday will score
alberto goes to third and alberto
monteci
as he has done
three different times it hasn't added up
to many games but he makes his presence
known immediately
bobby bradley austin hedges and andres
jimenez
strike three over the outside edge that
is 26 pitches and 20 strikes
salvador perez having a monster year
will lead off to kansas city third two
nothing royals
there's a ground ball backhanded by amid
rosario in short
and oh nice split save by bobby bradley
on the back end and ramirez moves up on
a wild pitch
change-up
reyes strikes out for a second time
jackson koar has four strikeouts in four
scoreless innings now monday who had two
very good swings on him
and there's a drive into deep left field
ramirez is back
my goodness
put on a show at alberto mondessie
in his first game since june the 20th
he has two hits
he has a stolen base and now he has a
home run
welcome back wow what a player indians
trailing three nothing as we head to the
fifth inning trying to break through
here against the rookie righty jackson
koar it's a base hit in the left field
by big harold
so he's back and the indians have
something brewing here in the 50.
it plays everywhere that's hit pretty
well deep left center field taylor on
the run runs it down drops the ball it
kicked off the end of his glove the
indians are going to score two runs
how about that he had to go all that way
and had it on the dead run and misses
the baseball watch his hand go up he's
got it he's got it he's calling for it i
don't know if the glove got in the way
and he was looking for the wall but you
got to catch that ball salvador perez
will step in perez oh for two he's fly
to center grounded to short
swing and a miss what an inning for
logan allen sets him down one two three
for the second down tonight and the
indians have two on with one out
and a change up is in for a called third
strike you're correct monty no doubt
about it with the fastball change-up
combination you know that's enough to
disrupt the timing but look at the
location there he's been able to put
that ball in the outer half away from
the hitter
change up
struck him out
x strikeouts five on the change
and jackson koar can walk off the mound
as a proud man tonight he's giving up
just two runs in six innings jake brent
is back from the injured list and he'll
hit the seventh inning
and a strikeout
on a slider you better than that
football hammered deep left field speeds
it up goodbye
oh baby you change stays locked in at
the plate a pinch hit home run puts the
indians in a tie it's a 3-3 game in the
seven
wow that is he did chang a favor boy and
a big herald leads off he's one for
three with a run scored
ripped to deep left field down the line
it is a
[Applause]
double into the corner ben attendee will
lob it back into the infield and the
indians have the go ahead run aboard to
start the ninth inning as big harrell
gets a lead off double in the ninth and
now oscar mercado will come in and run
it second and stay in the game and left
kickoff play at second base
out
and if it stands it'll be the second
pick off for the royals tonight so look
he's got a little generous that last of
the scotty boy what a throw
perfect timing on that pick off
cleveland will challenge
that's a close one get that tag on him
out
way to go
scotty boy
will come on for the tribe here in the
bottom half of the ninth just trying to
hold it right there and put a zero on
the board to give your chance in the
extra innings
swing and a miss bottom fell out of that
one and there are two down
dozier hits it on the ground left side
and that's going to be through so he
puts an end
to the o for 22.
[Applause]
goes after the first pick
and an easy out maybe gee whiz
bradley just got around claus a who
almost boxed him out
we've got extra innings in k.c
tied at three the royals with a chance
to win it and the royals will have the
top of the order up three good hitters
in whitmer field nikki lopez and
salvador perez
and on a hop to chang who bubbles throws
and gets dropped by bradley
swing and a miss he struck him out
one away
and the 2-0
is hit in the air
you chang comes in bobby bradley's there
now you says i'll take it he does and
the rabbit has been pulled from the hat
once again corbin irvin santana the
sixth royals pitcher of the night
little fister right field shallow it
drops and gets down and the indians will
take the lead incredible austin hedges
has done it again
right man in the right spot as you
always say and he's had a knack
for coming up with some big hits
boy oh boy with two outs you get the
opportunity i mean he gets enough of
this ball and the 1-2
is hammered left field it's going to get
down and go to the wall
bradley scores
here comes austin hedges they're going
to wave him here's the throw to the
plate and he's out from me to you
but the indians get another run
blew it by him book it trevor stefan
nails it down what a performance
austin hedges is fired up that was some
pure filth from stefan
as he strikes out a pair and the indians
come all the way back